[Music]
[Applause]
i just had the craziest weekend and i
gotta tell you about it
i was road tripping with wendy in the rv
and
i hit up dana white he's the president
of the ufc
and asked him if he would give me a
media pass to go to the fights this
weekend
and he said sure but you got to get here
24 hours in advance for a covet test
and i'm like right on so we haul ass to
vegas
and by the time we get there they've got
me
registered at the dopest hotel casino
called
red rock total luxury
to be as big of a ufc fan as i am
like this is just crazy and just a word
to the wise
if you're a baller you need to stay at
red rock
okay whoa yeah
dude unbelievable
no way for wendy's
mean the [ __ ] patio ridiculous
wow dude
holy [ __ ] anchor girl all right i'm all
showered up and it's time to go get
kovid tested
and i think that's all i'm going to do
is get a copic test but it turns out
the copic test is in dana white's office
have you had this test done we've had so
many common tests
that was among the more aggressive ones
that's why i get the test they're like
oh man ah
hang out here and then when you're
cleared go hang out with dana
yeah dude
and he gives me a tour of his office
tells me about his art this piece here
represents war obviously killing with
the gun on the knife
the clip those are all the things we
kill for wow oil
cocaine gold blood diamonds
religious symbols and the last one of
the seeds you make heroin with
that over there is a real samurai from
the early 1600s
that was his gear
[Laughter]
we just sat down and hung out for like a
half an hour
as a fan of the ufc and particularly a
fan of dana white
because he's the definition of boss
that alone was the greatest experience
ever good hang bro thank you so much man
good to see you
so i go back to the hotel just
lay into the room surface with the
seafood platter
fed wendy lobster
we crawl in this big gorgeous bed
i got footage of wendy and i sleeping
together i got an epic night's sleep man
now it's time to start the day
i had some time to kill played a little
bit of pull surprise myself by some of
the great shots that i made
i guess sure enough before long it was
time to go to the fights
so i head over to the ufc apex and they
send me right into this
vip viewing area which i've got all to
myself
and the fight that was actually
happening
when i walked in resulted in a
guy's ear being torn off not all the way
off
but like pretty much off i mean i loved
all the fights i'm tweeting away
i picked the fight of the night which
actually ended up being the fight the
night
then comes the main event and this of
course when
bruce buffer says his line
[Music]
[Applause]
which i love so much and uh
the main event i thought ended up being
the best fight of the night
and immediately after it was done they
brought me over
to go be on espn
which i was psyched about what a night
indeed that main event was
insane what do you think about that one
i had the fight of the night as the
barcelos taha fight absolutely until the
main event
and i mean what a main event some strong
analysis for you i thought from you i
feel like you might be after my job here
but i'm okay with it i'm okay with it
and then after my espn interview then i
went into the actual
press room and got to interview the guy
who won the main event
glover to shara yeah dude glover thank
you
man thank you for an incredible uh
main event i feel that you deserved the
fight of the night and a fighter bonus
thank you thank you big fan well thank
you and by the way
look at this ridiculous scene right here
[ __ ] killer weekend man thank you
dana white
whoa